ISSA:
I need advice.
Lawrence and I are... back.
Oh, shit. Really?
Does he know?
Yeah, he knows.
But if I'm seeing Lawrence,
I should maybe stop hanging out
with Nathan, right?
-That's messy.
-Yeah, could be a little messy.
Maybe I'm overthinking it.
Yeah.
You could be overthinking it.
Okay. This has been
very unhelpful. Thanks.
Whatever.
You get what you pay for. Bye!
♪ (UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Aye! Finish it off.
There you go.
Kelli. This liquor's gotta
last all day,
so you gotta stop
pouring so much.
I'm trying to help you out.
You know what they say,
"The stronger the libations,
the bigger the donation."
ISSA: (RAPPING)
CHAD:
What's taking you so long?
LAWRENCE:
Still getting my shit together.
Yeah? Well, why don't you get
your shit together, together?
That's what I told Lia.
We gon' handle her divorce
and our prenup at the same time.
That's just
good time management.
What?
TIFFANY: It's been so hard.
Like at the hospital,
I felt like
I was gonna pass out.
I told them.
No one would listen to me.
And it turned out
I had a blood clot.
ALL: Oh, my God.
-Are you serious?
-Yes!
Girl, these doctors
need to start listening to us.
That's how
they almost killed Serena.
Ooh, can you Yelp review
a maternity ward?
'Cause Imma give them
three stars. Three!
Men these days
are hella triflin'.
Just be thankful
you have Lawrence.
I don't know. I'm just stuck
in my own head.
Well, what you think therapy is?
I'm stuck in my head talking
to a stranger.
At least you get the option
to fuck at the end.
Let's go somewhere tonight.
Can you teach me how to ho?
Bitch, that's rude.
And yes.
ISSA:
-So who initiated the sex?
-Him. Basically.
-Have y'all spoken since?
-Yeah.
No.
ISSA:
My credit score can't be
that bad.
Bad would be a step up.
The basic credit tiers are
excellent, good, poor, bad...
then Issa, is all the way
at the bottom.
Speaking of needing places
to stay, Issa, an apartment
came through.
It's in your budget.
It's only got a half bath.
But there's a YMCA up the block
where you could shower after 6.
-Bam!
-Ooh, that sounds promising.
ISSA:
Y'all this is the first time
there's nothing in the way
of us getting together.
So isn't that worth exploring?
-ALL: No.
-Mm-mm.
So y'all just gon' Greek chorus
on a bitch?
ALL: Yes!
Dumb bitch.
(SINGING)
Maybe you should Airbnb
your new spot
so you can make some extra cash.
And where would I live?
That literally makes no sense.
You know who makes no sense?
Or dollars?
You.
-Ooh, I have been saving!
-Okay.
♪ I've been saving ♪
♪ I've been saving
I've been saving ♪
♪ I've been saving ♪
♪ She's been saving
She's been saving ♪
Ah, ah, ah! Uh-uh. Uh-uh. Uh-uh.
-No, you know I eat out a lot.
-KELLI: Oh, girl.
Rite Aid?
Who-- You buying groceries
at Rite Aid?
ISSA:
I buy panties there too.
CHAD: Condola talking
to ol' girl about you?
They gon' start a podcast
about your dick.
Fuck out of here, man.
Shut it down.
What if I just text Issa
and ask her to chill?
Nah, might come across
kind of harsh in a text.
How about a bitmoji of me saying
"keep my name out yo' mouth"?
Nah, you don't wanna start
texting.
Ol' girl can take your shit
out of context
and send you some titties.
All of a sudden,
you've got a paper trail
and blow up your whole shit
with Condola.
Condola come to me
'cause she all sad.
-I gotta put it on her, now--
-Man, shut the fuck up.
This is so nice!
I used to be like,
"She wants to do what? Why?
Where? How?
And for what purpose?
And then again why?"
Yeah, I was there.
Oh, but girl,
you made this happen.
I mean, this is awesome.
I'm just glad
you always believed in me.
MOLLY: Yes! I got a thumbs up
from the partner.
A bitch is officially free
to turn up!
See, when you work hard,
you play hard!
Mm. That's right. That's that
80-40 ratio right there.
It's overlap. I know math.
Kelli, I gotta do something.
I told Daniel I'd only be
staying there a few weeks,
and I don't wanna take advantage
of that.
Don't look a gift horse
in the dick.
That's not a saying.
It is. My grandmother said it
to me.
MOLLY: Well, listen.
I'm just glad you finally
getting your own place.
I mean, I'm not gon' lie.
Staying at Daniel's
is kinda nice.
What's so nice about sleeping
on the couch?
Mm.
So, you figured out how
to pay him after all?
Dot, dot, dot, dot, dot. Ass.
No.
What's the latest on Asian bae
by the way?
MOLLY: It's been almost a month,
and I'm just not feeling close
to him. It's weird.
It's all good sex
and witty banter, but--
Hold up, hold up.
He dicks you down,
makes you laugh,
and he don't work
at the airport?
What's the problem?
'Cause I don't hear it.
Who wants to sit around
and listen to a grown man
talking about his feelings?
You know what I want?
I want me a mime
with a big dick.
I'll be happy as hell.
I gotta find the circus.
Derek. Derek! Put on your cape.
-(STAMMERS)
-ISSA: Should I help her up?
KELLI: Don't help her.
She gotta learn.
Uh-uh. She gotta learn.
She gon' have to learn.
That's the first step
of motherhood.
She's pregnant with a baby.
I'm pregnant with ideas.
Y'all ain't help me up.
Your ideas are trash, Kelli.
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪